Troubleshooting a mobile device can be
problematic. So, it's useful to break
everything into smaller pieces and try
to troubleshoot a little bit at a time.
If you're having problem with an
application, especially applications
that will not launch or when you launch
them, they have very slow performance.
There are a number of different things
you can try. Unfortunately, most mobile
devices don't give you access to the
command line. So there's not a lot of
resources available for doing detailed
troubleshooting of apps. Fortunately,
the universal troubleshooting task of
turn it off and back on again does apply
in this particular situation. This way
you're able to clear out memory or any
stored caches and once the system is
back up and running, you can try
launching the application again and see
if it starts. It may be that the
application itself is having a problem
or it's hung and you may be able to
close the app and simply restart it
without having to restart the entire
mobile phone. On some iPhone versions,
you can double tap the home button and
slide up the app. Or you can simply
slide halfway, list out the apps, and
then slide the app completely off the
screen to close it out. You then simply
need to restart the app and see if it
performs better once it's restarted. On
Android, it's a similar process of going
to the settings, apps, selecting the
app, and then choosing the option to
force stop. And it could be that the
application you're using is a bit
outdated. It might have a bug that's
already been resolved, and the only way
to fix that would be to update the
application from the App Store or the
central application management on that
mobile device.
It could be the application problem
we're having causes the app itself to
hang. Or perhaps the app has an error
message or something on the screen where
it can give us some feedback about where
the problem might be occurring. But
sometimes your application simply
disappears and is no longer available on
your mobile device and you'd have to
restart it manually. This could be
related to the inner workings of the
operating system inside of that mobile
device. So restarting the mobile device
will clear the slate. We can try running
the app again. And again, this might be
related to a bug that's in the app. So
updating the application itself may end
up solving the problem that you're
having. And on many of these devices,
you can delete the app, go back to your
app store, and reinstall the app to make
sure that everything in that app is
installed properly.
You might also run into cases where
you're having a problem updating the
app. If you look at the list of
applications, it might show that the
application has an update, but when you
click the update button, it doesn't
update the app. This is sometimes done
automatically behind the scenes, but if
it's not performing the update process
on an automatic basis, you might have to
go into this view and manually choose
individual apps to update or choose the
option to update all. You might also
find that your app store will require
you to have a valid payment method
that's on file and configured in the app
store itself. And if your payment method
is no longer valid or it expires, you
may have to replace it with a newer
version. And of course, you can always
try turning off the mobile device and
turning it back on again. This will
clear out any pending updates, and it
may allow other updates to continue with
the update process.
Of course, all of these updates commonly
are downloaded directly from the
internet. So, if you're having a problem
with local connectivity to your network
or having a problem communicating to the
internet at all, then you obviously
won't be able to update any of these
apps. You might also want to check the
available storage space on your device
and make sure that you have enough room
to install a new application. Many of
these apps are very large and if you
have very limited space available, you
might have a problem during the update
process. And even though some of these
apps are free to download, you may still
find that they will not install unless
you have a valid payment method on file.
So check your App Store or Google Play
account and make sure that all of your
payment systems are up to date and
working properly.
If this is a mobile device that you're
using for work, there might be a policy
that prevents you from installing or
updating that application. Normally,
this is configured in your
organization's mobile device manager or
MDM. You can look at the list of
policies that are in your MDM to see
what options might be there for the
applications. Are your users allowed to
install applications from the iTunes
store? Can you use the news app or the
podcast app available to use? You can
configure almost every aspect of
usability for these mobile devices from
your mobile device manager. And on rare
occasions, you may find that the app
store is not available or it's currently
under maintenance. In those scenarios,
you'll have to wait for the app store to
get back up and running before you can
update any of your applications.
Our mobile devices often receive
updates. These might be new features
added to the operating system of the
device, or they might be bug fixes or
security updates. If you're trying to
install an update and it's not
installing, you may find that your
problem is related to the available
storage space. Many of these operating
system updates are much larger than
applications. So, you want to be sure
that you have plenty of space available
to install this latest operating system
patch. Since they are so large, you're
going to need enough bandwidth to be
able to download these in a reasonable
amount of time. So, you want to check
and make sure that you're on a
high-speed network and that you're able
to connect and transfer information at a
relatively decent rate. Some networks
have filtering built in that might
prevent you from visiting these app
stores and updating the operating system
or any applications. So, you might want
to move your mobile device to a
different network and see if you're able
to circumvent any filtering that might
be in place. And of course, turn your
device off and back on again and see if
clearing that device out and starting
from scratch will resolve any of these
update problems.
We rely on the batteries of these mobile
devices to keep them up and running
during our workday. But you may find
that your battery life tends to decrease
rapidly throughout the business day. It
may be that your device is just outside
of the range of your mobile network. If
that's the case, it will keep retrying
and retrying to try to obtain a signal
even though you're not doing anything on
that device. In that case, you might
want to try turning on airplane mode
even though you're on the ground. This
will turn off the radio and keep it from
eating away at that battery during the
day. And if this is an older mobile
device, it may be that the battery is
simply old and not able to maintain the
same charge that it once did. There's
obviously no easy fix for this one. You
would have to replace the battery to
regain any type of long-term battery
storage. There are things you can do
without having to make any changes,
though. We can try disabling anything
that we're not currently using. So, we
could disable 802.11 wireless,
Bluetooth, or GPS if we don't need those
services. And most of our mobile devices
these days provides you with a way to
check the health of your battery. You
can go into iOS or Android and choose
the options under settings and battery.
This will provide you information with
how your battery has been performing.
It'll show you the charging history for
your battery and how much you've been
using that battery over time.
I used to have a mobile phone that would
simply reboot itself in the middle of a
phone call. That was something very
abrupt. It was unexpected. There was no
message on the screen explaining why it
rebooted. It would simply restart and
then you'd have to make the call again.
For troubleshooting this problem, you
might want to start with the software.
Make sure your operating system and all
the apps that are running on your device
are up to date with the latest versions.
And of course, this could be related to
the hardware of the mobile device. So,
you might want to check the battery
health and see if other diagnostic tools
might be available on your mobile
device. This is a difficult problem to
troubleshoot and it often requires you
to go into the detailed logs of this
system to understand what occurred
during that reboot process. Your
technical support team should be able to
look at the crash logs on your device to
be able to determine why this may have
occurred and things that might be able
to help during the troubleshooting
process. In my particular case, this was
a hardware problem. we could see it in
the logs and we simply replace the phone
to resolve the issue.
These mobile devices often rely on a
solid network connection in order to
operate properly. And if you're running
into a problem with intermittent
connectivity, especially if you're
connected to a local wireless network,
you may want to try getting a little bit
closer to that access point and getting
a little bit more signal strength. or
you might want to try connecting to a
completely different access point to see
if the original access point may have
been your problem. If you're not getting
any Wi-Fi connectivity, you want to be
sure that you have enabled Wi-Fi and you
haven't accidentally turned it off in
the settings of your mobile device.
There's also security key configurations
and wireless settings that you want to
be sure match the wireless network that
you're connected to. And of course,
restarting that system will restart
everything, including the wireless
connectivity and allow you to start
troubleshooting using a clean slate. If
our issue is related to a Bluetooth
connection, then we obviously don't have
an access point that we need to worry
about, but we do need to check to see if
Bluetooth is enabled on that mobile
device. If our problem is connecting to
a previously paired Bluetooth component,
then perhaps turning off Bluetooth and
turning it back on might help you. And
ultimately restarting the entire system
might be the best way to confirm that
we're starting with a clean slate.
If you're running into problems using
near field communication or NFC, there
are a number of things that you could
check. You can, of course, enable or
disable that NFC connectivity, and that
might clear it out enough to get things
started to work again. Resetting the
device is always an option and often
we're using this NFC as a purchase
method. So we may want to make sure that
our payment systems and credit cards are
up to date inside of our mobile device.
We'll often use AirDrop to be able to
transfer information between our mobile
devices. And if you have a long distance
between those devices, you may not be
able to see the name of that device pop
up in your list. Getting closer to that
secondary device may allow you to then
see the name and be able to select it
for the file transfer. Features like
AirDrop rely on wireless communication,
and AirDrop uses both Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth. If you have both of those
turned on, you'll have the best
experience when trying to perform these
AirDrop functions. And if other devices
can't see your mobile device, it may be
that you've disabled AirDrop discovery
on your device. You may be able to turn
that off. You might want to set it to
contacts only or you might temporarily
want to turn it on so that everyone can
see your device.
We often use our mobile phone in a
portrait mode, but we might want to turn
it landscape to use an app or to take
pictures. But you might find a problem
auto rotating when you change your phone
from a portrait mode into more of a
landscape mode. Inside the phone is a G
sensor or accelerometer that recognizes
when it's moving between these different
modes. And if there is a problem with
that process, you may find that it
doesn't move whenever you change your
phone's direction. Most of these phones
also have a way to lock this process so
that you don't accidentally have it auto
rotate. So, you might want to check to
see if that lock has been enabled, and
that might solve your problem with auto
rotation. Sometimes an app might get
confused as to what type of rotation
it's currently using. So, by closing out
the app and restarting, you might be
able to solve that problem. Of course,
restarting the device might be an easy
fix, but if that doesn't solve the
problem, you'll want to contact device
support and see if they have a sensor
issue that they may be able to swap out.